i can't lead with that with sean casey
kind enough to get up and join us on the
program
but i will hey buddy how are you
[Laughter]
yeah you got your knees buckled well you
know what it's so great
i mean it's it's not great it's it's
just what an experience
is my last year with the red sox we're
in
vero beach right and uh and and it's
like the sixth inning i'm trying to get
some work in we you know
i'm it's probably going to be my last at
bat and uh
i look out on the mound it's like number
98. it's this big dude looks like a
young kid
you know and i'd say to dave magnet i
was like who is this guy
you got anything on him he's like nah i
don't know man like some rookie they
just brought up to get some innings and
i'm like all right so i go to tito i'm
like
hey tito i'm like uh i've seen this guy
before he's like some rookie they
brought up off the back field so i'm
like all right that's cool
so i go up there you know i'm leading
off the inning and i see a couple
pitches you know lining them up
danny i get in there first pitch boom
i'm ready to go
bam 98 outside corner i'm like
and i look over i swear i step out and
i'm kind of like is it is this a joke
cause it's a joke on me i'm looking
around
i look over at joe torre who's the
manager of the dodgers at ty larry bo
they're just like they're giggling
around like you know
oh man they know something i don't know
so i get back in deep breath
you know i'm like come on i'm a 12 year
vet i'm going to dominate here next
pitch
wham just one of the most unbelievable
hammers i've ever seen
coming at my face and i'm just like
start buckling right
damn strike two i'm like oh my gosh this
is
this is unbelievable and now tori and
those guys are crying laughing
next pitch he paints it outside black i
mean it was like 97
bam and i look back and the umpire calls
it a ball i'm like oh man that's like a
veteran move like
he doesn't know who this guy is either
but we've never seen stuff like this
so i look back i'm like thank you next
pitch i mean
literally i thought it was gonna hit me
curveball boom strike three
i mean just tony's frozen pizza is like
don't know what to do just
right here i'm out right and i walked
back and i
i said to a frank cona i go you don't
know who this guy is
and tito goes i don't know but i'm just
glad i'm not you
[Laughter]
you called that the nastiest pitch you
ever faced that curveball that he threw
you back then
i i swear you know all those years in
the big leagues facing different guys i
mean zito had a good curveball
but i've never seen 97 like darted down
and then a hook like that and it was it
was it was like
it was like he threw it up in the spin
and it was scary i thought it was gonna
hit me and i just like
i like turned into a four-year-old kid
like mommy you know
it was unbelievable man he made me look
like and then he got called up
later in that year and i was like that's
the guy that's the guy
that's the guy i faced and then when he
started dominating i was like yes he's
dominating everybody
did you ever talk to kirsh shaw about
that at bat
oh i did yeah i think a couple years
later at the all-star game i was working
for mlb network and i was out there you
know interviewing guys and i and i think
one of the first things i asked him was
hey man you did me dirty bro yeah i
didn't even know who i didn't even know
who you were
and he goes hey i had to go i knew i was
facing sean casey something like that
he's like i had to get him i'm like oh
man you got me all right like i felt so
so small i was like i need to retire i
need to retire
uh all right let's start with uh the
move last night
when cash goes to the mound now what did
you think
that he should do with blake snell in
that moment
boy i i just i just know as a hitter
when
there's certain guys that are on the
mound and you know i know i know he
punched out mookie twice
he had punched out uh seeger and turner
twice
and i understand what cash is saying
because that's what they've done all
year long so
you know i know they don't like to have
the um the pitcher face that line up
three times
but i know snell was dominant i mean he
was just had great stuff
so for me as a hitter if you've punched
me out twice i'm not looking forward to
that third time up that means something
really good is happening out there
and so i kind of i just i love cash a
great friend of mine i disagreed with it
because i know
as a hitter let's just get this guy out
of here as quick as we can
i mean bring a guy in with a rocket
launcher i don't care just i need
i need to see something else besides
what's going on out there so
i don't know man i'm second guessing
cash and they're in the world series for
a reason but i would not have taken
snell out right snell out right there
yeah and mookie said after the game he
was like man i was relieved that they
took him out because i felt like i now
i had a chance and you know they brought
in anderson and he had been hitting
right-handers better than left-handers
yeah i think yeah what was it mookie's
slugging percentage off
off lefties was like 218. and so it just
didn't make sense
and anderson was the one guy too that
like i know he's been really good these
last few years but
he hasn't had a great postseason he's
the one guy i felt like was pretty
hittable and when mookie got that double
i was like
oh here we go what do you think is the
future of analytics and baseball
well that's a great question because i
really i think
i think there's i think it's going to
come back around again like i
i just really believe there is something
to be said
like about the mental side of the game
about the flow of the game the mojo of
the game about really seeing what your
eyes are seeing you know i
you know you can't judge like i always
people always say about hitting i'm like
listen
when i'm in the box like i really am
trying to dumb things down
i'm trying to see the ball and hit the
ball like i'm really trying to like uh
you know slow the game down like there's
no analytics that can help me with that
stuff and
you need a human being to be able to
measure hey man he's really seen the
ball whether or he's feeling good today
i talked to when he came to the yard so
i think there's going to be
i think there's going to be more of that
i think we're starting to get analytics
heavy
and i just think it's the cycle is going
to bring it back to
hey we still need those baseball guys
that have that that past the eye test
i love that mookie betts was on display
for the nation
to see because i baseball has become
regional
but i'm i i'm glad that people got to
see him and he does
everything he's not one-dimensional
which a lot of our baseball players now
are one-dimensional or it feels that way
he did it on the basis he did it in the
field he did it at the plate
and i can't say enough about him i i
love watching him play i think he's very
smart
um he's not a big guy
but he's not afraid and i know seeger
got the mvp
i think that you know i think mookie was
the mvd the most valuable dodger
yeah i think so i mean i think he put
them over the top too i think without
mookie bets they don't win the whole
thing
and you're right danny man when you
watch him play it's everything you'd
want to bring your son to watch like
you know hey watch this guy hit then
when he gets on base it's like okay now
you're a base runner
you know he he does everything the way
he cuts the corners the way he gets
jumps
i loved it last night after the game
they asked him about you know the read
he got
you know scoring scoring from third base
and he said hey listen i knew i needed
to get a big secondary i knew i needed
to
get going quickly and i was able to do
that like i just love the fact
that he runs the base as well he plays
gold glove defense he hustles on and off
the field
he can hit he just does everything that
you would want to see a baseball player
do
and that's why he's one of the best in
the game i brought this up to the
commissioner last week where
i understand you're going to have a
shift but i can't have
i would prefer not to have the shortstop
on the other side of second base
or second base on the other side of uh
you know second base with the shortstop
i just don't want extreme
shifts is is that am i asking too much
there
is it fixable i mean i i kind of feel
the same way you do i
i don't know like is it like the illegal
defense kind of thing in the nba or you
know i mean i think
i feel the same way sometimes too and
you know it's such a big deal now it's
such a
a big thing to see hey guys are beating
the shift in the postseason they're
going the other way they're staying
inside it you know
and you know people always say well if
they start to do that they'll
shift back well you're not going to ask
your big
power hitters to just beat the shift all
the time you've got to actually hit the
ball at a ballpark
nowadays in this game but i agree with
you man i don't i don't love the shift
and i know people say hey it's a
strategy thing
i get it but you know everyone's on one
side of the field and like
i don't know i don't love it and the
justin turner situation last night
like how bizarre is this that in the
middle of
game six of the world series
i mean i don't know what would happen if
there was a game seven
because justin turner was around all of
his teammates
i mean nothing had changed it felt like
once the game started
sean then you know what everybody gets
to play
the rest of the game like it i don't
know it just felt
you imagine this in the super bowl third
quarter
somebody's you know they have an
inconclusive test and then they take
another one and they go out and play and
then they go in the third quarter
uh hey uh you know tom brady uh come
here you guys sit down you uh you tested
positive
oh my gosh no i mean seriously i mean
it's crazy
it's almost par for the course for this
year you know it's just
oh the world series your number three
hitter has coveted in the middle of the
game
it's crazy and i it was weird because
joe buck kept saying you know turner's
out of game we'll have to find out why i
mean i
never would have in my wildest dreams
thought yeah he left the game in the
middle of the game with kovid like
that's
just crazy and then you're right onto
the field too
you know after this and he'd been told
he'd been told not to go out there on
the field
i know you want to celebrate but and
maybe he thought look
i've been around these guys i'm going
out there to celebrate i understand
where what his thought process is but
for major league baseball
you can't let justin turner go out there
if you're pulling him from the game you
can't go on the field to celebrate
yeah i'm sure emotions were so high with
with turner and that
you know i don't know you know i don't
know what i would have done there but
yeah you're right i mean it's
it's one of those things where it's a
very touchy thing and
you know you don't want to put other
people in danger well i would want to go
out and celebrate with my teammates i
don't even know if i'll be with the
dodgers next year he's a free agent i
understand it's the best biggest moment
of your baseball career
but major league baseball or the dodgers
have to say
justin you can't go out there you can't
go out yeah i mean it's
tough yep i agree i agree with you
anybody have more energy than you
yeah brett phillips i think does
did you ever have a manager get talked
out of taking a pit
like you would be on the mound at first
base did you ever hear a conversation
where a pitcher
talked his manager out of taking him out
of a game
was there any weird um uh
let me see have i yeah
i'm sure i did i can't think it went off
off the top of my head it doesn't
i didn't it didn't happen too often i
mean there might have been one or two
times but
you know i'm sure i did but i you know i
i love it i love it when
when you you're able to have that
conversation if the manager comes out
and and the pitcher says no i'm not
coming out of this game
you know i i don't know if that happens
the way it did back in the day danny but
you know i i i i've seen it a couple of
times
you never went to the manager and said
you know what i think you should pull it
no i never did never did you know i kind
of relied on the manager to just to just
you know
do that i remember dave dave miley went
dave miley one time came out to the
mountain
he was like we came you know we were
meeting at the mountain he hadn't got
anybody he's like
about to get the lefty he looked at me
he's like in case i got to go with the
lefty right here i'm like
i don't know i just played first base
that's your decision
get the lefty the righty whoever you
think just do it did a pitcher ever ask
the manager to
have you pulled from the game
oh thanks for getting up always great to
see you enjoy the off season there sean
thank you buddy
okay danny thanks a lot man see you soon
brother that's sean casey